hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for fortnight chapter 2 season
2 my friends this is the series where we
look at all the map changes from the
huge game changing landmarks to the tiny
subtle inconsequential updates only true
nerds like you and I appreciate please
think about using cold a tomorrow in the
fortnight's shop to keep the series
going and as always likes and subs help
us reach more people if you're ready for
this let's go through 30 map changes in
10 minutes oh let's do this it's
difficult to choose where to start oh I
know I know
finally the house which replaced our hot
watch desires has been completed this
looks to be a facility for the shadow
unit to keep tabs on their ghost
counterparts I suppose we should get
used to that right now it's no longer
ego versus altar they are ghost and
shadow this season looks to be created
like season 4 in Chapter 1 ie the
greatest season ever in my opinion so if
you had to choose right now right this
instant this very second are you in team
ghost or the shadow squad what would you
pick I think I'm going ghost for one
last final time let's hear the house
watch theme over the last seven days the
central island has slowly seen gold
items replaced the normal ones after all
the teasers we finally have a full
update to that location and look how
insane it is the home base of the ghost
unit complete with helipad and Atlas
style statues this place has been
through a lot already from cabins to a
boss fight with a god back to cabins
again and now this this is what we like
epic keep map changes like this one
coming and an FYI you don't die if you
stand in the torches lovely
over the past few months we'd been
watching a very very very slow-moving
flatbed truck traverse the map after a
delivery of chairs was made at the docks
we saw them loaded onto this truck and
the last four weeks they've sat dormant
by the first bridge well now there is
movement it's only about 100 meters down
the road but progress is progress so
let's celebrate that GG's by the way all
the outdoor toilets you see all the way
around the map now you should totally
jump in them just in case because some
of them lead to super secret underground
facilities like this there's one
actually by the chair truck right now
another is in pleasant park in fact
they're everywhere some dumpsters work
too and the red phone boxes are your
opportunity to become Clark Kent
becoming Superman change disguise at
these places
pretty damn epic I ventured back to the
bunker to see what had updated and alas
zero zilch nothing absolutely nothing at
all which is a shame but we're looking
for positives here nearby is a new
location a new delivery Depot Depot
whatever you like has popped up and
there isn't much to look at here but if
you like dropping at the shiver in over
the winter period this could be your new
home and I suspect it'll be pretty quiet
here too another humungous update sees a
yacht appear just above steamy stacks
this behemoth is packed with floor drops
and chests and the new vaults which are
seen in other spots on the island - as
this will likely be a hot spot the
reboot fan has moved to a newly created
island nearby any myth chases in the
house I wondered if the ship was
syncopal so here's my test
darn it sadly not to this base is
permanent let's go back in time remember
the old RadioShack from chapter 1 of the
season
this was the home oven built nothing
really except the fearless leader Graham
the genome just before the season ended
the radio station had the start of an
update with pallets and potential walls
arriving well check back this season
this place has had a full-on upgrade it
is complete with a basement to explore -
on the roof our training dummies so
whoever set this up is preparing for
action the radio tower has been upgraded
- but the moment we really need to take
in here
will Graham the king of the gun ohms be
ok
[Music]
hell yeah gram is bossing it up there
you know what today in the comments I'm
going to look for anyone saying
all hail Graham I'll be replying out of
nowhere next we have the grotto a
cave-like facility built into the walls
of a cliff and hilltop it's like a real
James Bond villains lair here with a
waterside entrance and an air pocket
like vacuum just like steamy stacks for
great mobility if you land here be aware
there are zip lines above so someone
will likely crash your party at any time
there's another Bop here by the way
a tiny update just up the hill is a
small mobile home this is one I'm not
too certain about what's this here last
season I can't be certain I've never
really landed here is this new or have I
simply just never been here before
let's jump down to retail row every time
I come here I always check out the star
it's usually a shell of nothingness but
at Halloween and Christmas time things
take shape while in season two the star
has been broken into two offices one for
the ghosts one for the shadows they are
keeping such a close eye on one another
if you do see yourself drop here look on
the desk the old ego file from the
toilet last season that is the weirdest
thing I've said for a long time I wonder
if these files will be important
on the west side of the map another
layer has been erected in the cove a
shark shaped base which looks so badass
in terms of loot there's logged so
expect to be pushed when dropping here
the boats nearby allow for a quick
getaway so keep that in mind
oh and look at the island closest there
is a start of another map update here a
very quick and down and dirty spy nest
has been created to keep tabs on the
shark lair Oh now's a good time to note
a series of map changes in one fell
swoop all the ego outposts from last
season have gone straight up vanished
all over the map only a few supplies
remain on the ground and the grass has
also died there so we can remember these
locations the first one found by the
beach has gone the one in the mountains
near the disco that's gone too you get
the idea right
ego outposts from season 1 I've gone oh
man that means even the huge barracks
below Holly hedges has gone too gone but
not forgotten
rip the dream here's a great little map
change which has zero impact on anything
at all a police chase has gone horribly
wrong on the way out of sweaty sands a
police speed trap has caught a law
breaker who has smashed through the
barricade and overturned on the roadside
it's like fast and furious hot night
edition
maybe that's the Future crossover I'm
calling it now a cool touch here is the
stirring which has also been taken out
to go further south towards Holly hedges
is a strange house we saw slowly being
stripped back as if it was tunneling
into the ground well they sure did it
the house is now an outpost for the
shadow squad complete with a basement
and a little more loot than it had
previously these slow updates are my
personal favorites it really feels like
the island is evolving rather than
suddenly changing I love it
what about you here's another tiny
update which is likely nothing but I
wanted to be sure down by the tree
nursery we've been waiting for the
flatbed trucks to get a move on now
three months later they still haven't
moved but check this out one of the
trucks from logjam is now passing by
where could it be going and why is that
more important than these two I need
answers to my pointless questions epic
the hill from here is another outpost
from season two instead of the military
looking buildings this is built out of
stone and looks super professional the
ghosts are more about style this season
I like that
[Music]
one more huge update before we look at
the ultra small changes there's an oil
rig yes yeah I know you've noticed it
but there wouldn't be a map change video
unless I pointed it out okay
sadly just like the yards this is
indestructible in certain places blue I
wonder if there's a reason why the oil
rig and the yachts are at exactly
opposite points on the map could this be
a story theme or maybe a new game mold
coming soon I can't wait to find out
let's keep going with small changes this
house outside pleasant park is this new
or am I just blind as a bat I feel like
I feel like it's new is it new
anyway regardless of that another cool
update will find these around the map
hosters attempting to recruit you like
the old world war posters and then ones
we saw in chapter 1 and going around the
map you'll also spot some mail drops the
first one I found was outside the former
star in retail row oh and just before I
uploaded this I also noticed this one of
the wagons has completely crashed above
the swamplands what could this mean
I have no idea but I like things like
this
okay before we finish I have a question
for you
in the season 2 trailer a tree with
carvings on it can be seen what looked
to be telling us about the 7 I need to
know more about this it's part of the
story but I can't find this tree
anywhere in the world if you find it
please DM me on Twitter and I will gift
you something in return if you are the
first my name is Adam grenade over there
and my DMS are always open so there we
have it
13 map changes in 10 minutes how did I
do
did you notice anything else I must have
missed something right oh also if you
want to have a crack at a story theory
please let me know I want to bring them
back to this series each week but I
definitely need some help a quick shout
out to those people who use my code
Adam arrow in the last week of season
one I really appreciate you helping me
out when updates were few and far
between
I hope this season I can pay you back a
little bit more with more content but
for now thank you is all I can say
please think about using code Adam arrow
it makes a massive difference to my life
and what I can produce thank you for
your time it's been an absolute pleasure
I'll see you very soon
[Music]
the squat for the wind go squad for the
wind I'm still recording